to uvalde texas where public schools
will reopen this morning for the first
time since may's mass shooting robb
elementary however where 19 students and
two teachers were murdered that school
remains closed other schools are now
surrounded by protective fencing with
additional security cameras and upgraded
door locks but some parents and students
say they still do not feel safe lilia
luciano was in uvalde immediately after
the shooting and she's been there many
times since she spoke to families one
family in particular devastated by the
massacre lilia good morning
good morning to you tony we're in front
of dalton elementary as you can see
behind me this is one of the schools
that has that eight foot non-scalable
fence but this is one of a few not every
school has expenses and not all parents
say that they feel comfortable with
these kinds of fences i was able to
speak last night with angelique
rodriguez she lost her twin sister
annabelle rodriguez during the shooting
at rob elementary and she and her
parents say that they're angry that
neither the school district or the state
are doing enough to keep kids safe
it's just the fact that
77 minutes you know a lot of those kids
who could have still been alive
when the surveillance video from the
hallways of rob elementary was leaked
donnie ray valdez and monica gallegos
were in washington dc advocating for
change in the nation's gun laws
their daughter angelique rodriguez says
police did not do their job
technically not they could have just
went in
angelie and her older sister saw the
clips online showing officers waiting
more than 70 minutes before stopping the
shooter whenever they heard the gunshot
she got his yarn back
they ran back
and they could have just ran in there
but they didn't what did that make you
feel like
she said not safe on the other side of
that door was her twin sister annabel
rodriguez who lost her life that day
what was she like
she
is
amazing she was amazing
anjali looked
up to annabelle a lot she needs her
sister it's hard that she's gonna have
to
enter
the following grades without her sister
this semester anjali isn't just starting
fifth grade without her twin sister she
and her older sister won't be in a
classroom at all instead they'll be
taught from home i just don't feel safe
sending them to school despite newly
installed eight-foot fencing and more
than a dozen other enhanced security
measures at district schools anjalee's
parents say it's still not enough what
would you like to see that they do in
the school that they haven't it's
the accountability part all those cops
all those school cops you know let's get
rid of them i say let's get some people
there are very highly trained i can't
see through that guys the couple says
gun reform is needed in texas
we
will not relent
until uvalde recovers what would you
like to hear or see from your governor
special session called a special session
you know let's let's get that age limit
up you know well let's take a step we'll
take a step
21 you know if if that if that kid
weren't able to get that gun so easy
you know we'd have a lot of those kids
still here
less than a week ago during a campaign
event republican governor greg abbott
said this change that these families
want in the law raising the minimum age
to buy an assault style rifle from 18 to
21 may be unconstitutional even though
other states have passed these laws tony
lilia thank you once again from vivaldi
texas uh i mean the central agony in the
lives of those parents remains whether
you put cameras up you put fences up
nothing's going to change it like so
many other families in other parts of
the country they're now moving into
advocacy looking for reform to gun laws
see if they get it it's still hard tony
when you see the video of the officers
in the hallway that's still shot of the
guy using hand sanitizer and other
people on the phone is still
heartbreaking i'm thinking about this
the fletcher family in memphis too we've
had back-to-back stories we realize
there hasn't been an identity yet but
i've been watching that story all
weekend and it's just heartbreaking the
end does not look so good for that
family it's tough and when footage
exists the footage is very haunting
tough to watch exactly right all right
lily thank you once again